hey everyone i'm shamley and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn
on merkle tree in blockchain in this
video
at first we will see some of the use
cases of merkle tree
and then we will understand what is a
merkle tree
followed by what is a marble root
after which we will explore about
cryptographic hash functions in
blockchain
and then we will understand how mongol
tree exactly works
after which we will discuss the benefits
of mochal3
and at last we will explore why is it
essential to blockchain
so without much delay let's get started
with the video
but before starting let's have a quick
look at some general use cases of merkle
tree
of course there are more merkle trees
implementations out there
git a distributed version control system
is one of the most widely used
it is used to handle projects by
programmers from all around the world
interplanetary file system a
peer-to-peer distributed protocol
is another suitable implementation it's
also open source
allowing computers to join and use a
centralized file system
merkle trees are used to benefit of
certificate authorities as well
it's part of the technique that
generates verifiable certificate
transparency logs
the final use case we'll look at is
database systems like
amazon dynamodb and apache cassandra
during the data replication process
merkle trees are used by these no sql
distributed databases
to control discrepancies
now the very first thing we will discuss
is what is a mockultry
merkle trees also defined as binary hash
trees are a type of data structure
commonly used in computer science merkle
trees are used to encrypt blockchain
data
more effectively and securely in bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies
it's a mathematical data structure made
up of hashes
of various transactions of various data
blocks
in a particular blockchain network which
acts as a summary of all the
transactions in a block
it also enables quick and secure content
verification across
big data sets it also helps to verify
the consistency
and content of the data
now that we know about the merkle tree
let's explore what is a merkle root
a merkle root is a simple mathematical
method for confirming the facts on a
mogul tree
they are used in cryptocurrency to
ensure that data blocks sent through a
peer-to-peer network
are whole undamaged and unaltered
muggle roots play a crucial role in the
computation
required to keep cryptocurrencies like
bitcoin and ether running
now that we know hash is a big part of
mughal tree let's dive down and have a
look at some of the cryptographic hash
functions
a hash function maps any type of
arbitrary data
of any length to a fixed size output it
is commonly used in cryptography
since it is a cryptographic hash
function
the hash functions are efficiently known
for one property they can't be reversed
it's a one-way function that's only
meant to work in one direction
message direct secure hash function and
ripe message direct are some of the
hash families available now let's take
an
example if you use the sha 256
hash algorithm and pass 101 blockchains
as input
you will get the following output this
concludes
that hash functions have the following
key properties
deterministic pre-image resistant
computationally efficient cannot be
reversed engineered
and collision resistant now that we know
about various aspects of the merkle tree
let's understand how the mercury works
now that we have a basic understanding
of hash functions
we can move on to the working of mobile
trees
a merkle tree totals all transaction in
a block and generates a digital
fingerprint of the entire set of
operations
allowing the user to verify whether a
transaction is included in the block
merkle trees are made by hashing pairs
of nodes
repeatedly until only one hash remains
this hash is known as the merkle root or
the root hash
they are built from the bottom using
transaction ids which are hashes of
individual transactions
each non-leaf node is a hash of its
previous hash
and every leaf node is a hash of
transactional data of each block
here's the example of a mokul tree to
help you understand the concept
consider the following scenario a b
c and d are four transactions all
executed on the same block
each transaction is then hashed leaving
us with
hash a hash b hash c
and hash d now the hashes are paired
together resulting in hash
a b and hash cd
a mogul root is formed by combining
these two hashes
hash a b c d
in reality a merkle tree is much more
complicated especially when each
transaction id is
64 characters long but this should give
you a
good concept of how the algorithms work
and why they are so effective
now let's explore the benefits of mogul
tree
merkle trees provide four significant
advantages
validate the data's integrity it can be
used to effectively validate the data's
integrity
takes little disk space when compared to
other data structures
the mogul tree takes up very little disk
space
timely information across networks
muggle trees can be broken down into
small pieces
of data for verification
and efficient verification the data
format is efficient
and verifying the data's integrity takes
only a few moments
now that we know the benefits of murkle
free let's explore
how it is essential to blockchain
let's imagine a blockchain without
mercury
to get a sense of how vital they are for
blockchain technology
we'll focus on bitcoin because it's use
of mongol trees is not only important
for the cryptocurrency
but also simple to grasp
if bitcoin didn't include morgle trees
for example every node on the mob
network would have to retain a complete
copy of every single bitcoin transaction
ever made you can imagine how much
information that would be
any authentication request on bitcoin
would require
an enormous amount of data to be
transferred on the over the network
therefore you'll need to validate the
data on your own
to confirm that there were no
modifications
a computer used for validation would
need a lot of computing power to compare
ledgers
well merkel tree are a solution to this
issue
they hash records and accounting thereby
separating the proof of data from the
data itself
proving that giving tiny amounts of
information across the network
is all that is required for a
transaction to be valid
furthermore it enables you to
demonstrate that both ledger variations
are identical in terms of nominal
computer power
and network bandwidth well
that is all about mercury we have almost
reached the end of this video
if i missed anything important do let me
know in the comment section
i hope you enjoyed this video on merkle
tree in blockchain
and learn something new from it if you
like this video then please do hit the
like button thanks for watching this
video
and stay tuned for more updates and
videos from simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here